Canadian icon Celine Dion stop by watch
what happens live where she judged an
incredible drag competition featuring
some of her most memorable looks and
opened up about her life her career and
her new album courage while taking
questions from host Andy Cohen and fans
from across North America Celine of
course kept things candid as always
discussing dating and romance rumors
would you ever consider getting
remarried and are you currently dating
you're supposed to ask one question just
I don't date I don't have a boyfriend
and you know it doesn't mean that I will
not find someone in my life if I do that
would be great if I don't that would be
great because I'm still in love I mean
once you're in love so much you know
I've been living all my life with Rene
is still within me I see him through the
eyes of my children every day I'm so
passionate about life and I'm so lucky
to have my three beautiful sons that's
beautiful that I keep everything I'm not
looking for that something that happens
that you feel that comes and you feel
and right now it's it's it's it's if I
would have someone in my life I would
tell you because I've got an open book
all my life as for the fanfare
surrounding her relationship with dancer
and stylist Pepe me knows I was not
surprised no you know I was not
surprised it's just that because we're
best friends
yeah we're in show business and the
tabloids and the this industry is made
for that right oh that's the way that
best friends hold hands uh-uh right it
feels like today you cannot have a man
holding your hand know anything about
him he's holding his energy so they go
out together they started things until
one day I said he's gay he's not my calm
down okay I'm not trying to hide here
yes everything's cool yes but we can't
hold hands yeah go to do movies and
restaurants come on people let Queen
Celine live the five-time gran
winter also revealed some surprising
facts I've got a few of her biggest hits
including my heart will go on there's
one song that I didn't want to record
which was what and I'm glad that they
didn't listen to me which was my heart
will go on no it is true
Wow why didn't you want to record it I
don't know yeah it didn't it didn't
appeal to me it didn't appeal to me I
was probably very tired that day Wow
very tired God they did and my husband
said that's me let's hold on
yes that's what a writer and he says
let's try to make it like a little demo
and I sang the song once and they built
the orchestra around it I never resign
it Wow for the recording actually so the
demo is the actual recording Wow but
after that I've sang it about three
gazillion times of course and a cover of
all by myself produced by legendary
Canadian composer David Foster so how on
earth did you hit that high note and all
by myself and what was the toughest part
of recording that songs well first of
all it was a very surprising note for me
because previous weeks before I recorded
that song David Foster calls me and I
was in Montreal he was in California in
Malibu and he calls me and he said
Celine do you mind - because I'm doing
I'm putting the song together all by
myself and he said I'd like to know
which key we should go for so I go to
the basement
I don't play piano but I can hit one key
and I was like okay which I think I said
David I think that's pretty cool he says
yeah I think we got it okay thank you
bye good luck thank you so much can't
wait my eye right to the studio he says
you're gonna you're gonna freak it's so
amazing but he said I have a little
surprise for you and I'm like oh okay
and he plays me to track it when I was
young and it's starting it's so and
diviner it's so beautiful and then he
said wait at the bridge I did a little
something and then the key that we have
agreed on he changed it to a key and a
half for the modulation by myself
more each and I was like is that the
final the key that finishes is the key
that we chose right no he says it's a
key and a half higher oh my god but I
said David how could you do that right
what he said if you can't do it there's
other singers and eggs over that case
yeah and that's all I needed to hear the
note yes I'm sure
[Applause]